All right.
Welcome everyone, to session two of the New
Drugs on the Horizon. It's my pleasure to be here.
I'm Danette Daniels,
a vice president at Foghorn Therapeutics.
And my co-chair, Monica Scannone from
Pfizer.
So just a few introductory remarks
about
both the New Drugs on the Horizon, but also the
Chemistry and Cancer Research, which supports the New Drugs on
Horizon, as well as several other activities here at AACR.
We do have tomorrow evening,
an Outstanding Achievement in Chemistry and Cancer Research
Award, which this year goes towards Dr.
Cheryl Arrowsmith of University of Toronto.
Her lecture will be at 5:15 to 6:00 PM.
This will be immediately followed by the CICR Town Hall,
where we have a really exciting panel and
have partnered this year with the Hematological
Malignancies Working Group. So we'll be focusing on From
Molecules to Medicine: Driving Breakthroughs in Blood Cancer
Treatment. And after the town hall, we have a very nice
networking reception where you can meet both
people in the CICR as well as the Heme Working Group.
We're also very pleased to announce this year we were able to
raise money,
and support eight conference travel awards for
early career scientists, so graduate students and postdoctoral
fellows, to attend this year's annual meeting.
And
we hope to continue this program as the years go on.
And so I have a QR code here for anyone who
is interested to help us with this program and donate,
so that we can really support the next generation.
And lastly,
this New Drugs on the Horizon is a
very special series held here at
AACR. We've been holding this since 2010.
We get numerous submissions every year and choose 12
talks to be covered.
You'll see they're a mix of modalities,
both biologics as well as small molecules and
macrocycles.
Everything covered here in New Drugs on the Horizon.
These are indeed first disclosures and
reveal a lot of breakthrough biology.
So,
a very special series here within AACR.
So I'd like to get started with this session.
Our first speaker will be Dr. James Broderick, who
is the CEO and founder of Palleon
Pharmaceuticals, and he will be giving a talk on a
first-in-class B7H3 targeted
sialidase for boosting innate and adaptive anti-tumor
immunity. So James?
Yeah, thank you very much.
This is an area of new biology.
We call it glycoimmunology.
And so what I'm going to do is I'm going to walk you through the foundational
science, where it came from, our
first-generation molecule, what we learned.
Then we'll talk about the new molecule and why it's better, and where we plan to
develop it. And then happy to answer questions at the end.
So just big picture, checkpoint inhibitors have transformed
oncology,
but most patients still don't respond.
So we see maybe up to a third of patients in many indications with
some benefit,
which is a huge advance, but
there's a lot of unmet need.
And what we see is that incremental improvements
targeting the same old pathways keep happening over and over and over
again. Tens of billions invested with only
modest overall survival gains. So we got to do something
different.
And so what we think at Palleon is that addressing the majority of the
non-responders is going to require a totally different distinct
axis of immune evasion. And that's what we're going to talk about today.
So I'd like to introduce you to the concept of tumor
hypersialylation. These are post-translational
modifications, glycosylation changes on tumor
surfaces. And so what we see in cancer, actually the majority of
the time, is cancer cells upregulate
sialic acid-containing glycans, otherwise called
sialoglycans, on their surface. And these are
symbolized by these little purple diamonds.
And there's a lot of literature on this.
Hypersialylated glycans engage multiple sialic
acid-dependent inhibitory pathways on immune
cells, actively
suppressing anti-tumor immunity.
And this is a great new discovery, but the problem is
conventional targeting with antibodies or small molecules can't overcome the
redundancy. There's literally hundreds or thousands of
variants of the sialoglycans, multiple different
receptors that are involved. It's a many-to-many biology.
It's almost like trying to block velcro versus blocking lock and
key.
And so we figured out how to make this whole area druggable.
So just a little bit of background information.
My co-founder, Carolyn Bertozzi, is really one of the pioneers in the field.
She's a Nobel winner in chemistry, and she basically
provided the first mechanistic characterization of
sialoglycan-mediated immune suppression about a decade
ago.And there had been a lot of support for this going back
decades. Over 50 studies showing tumor hypersialylation
was linked to poor outcome in over a dozen tumor types.
And actually, in clinical practice, we actually use hypersialylated
glycoproteins, sialylated glycoproteins, as prognostic
markers. This is part of routine clinical practice.
These are markers that show that, say, for instance,
ovarian cancer is back. But nobody knew why.
But the signal was quite robust. There was even some clinical evidence.
There were two crazy groups back in the '70s, one in Germany, one in New
York, that had actually experienced with,
basically, live tumor vaccination.
They showed better clinical results with a desialylated version.
So there was hints that there may be sialoglycans mattered.
They were linked to poor outcome. They may do something to the immune system.
And then more recently, we have some human data showing that this
is a very ripe area for development.
So what do we do? We're doing enzymatic desialylation.
It's the only way to overcome this redundancy of a many-to-many biology.
And what it does is it actually positively impacts antitumor innate and
adaptive immunity. So this framework of a cancer
cell evading the immune system by this glycan-mediated
mechanism, what we do is we have a drug that targets the
tumor with the tumor targeting arm, and then the sialidase
takes off all the sialic acid. And when that happens, all the
neoantigens are exposed. The drag on innate immunity is taken
away. We actually see enhanced innate and adaptive immunity.
So we're enhancing antibody effector function by removing the sialic
acid. We have a profound effect on pro-fibrotic
CD163 positive M2 macrophages. We actually have paired
biopsy experience in humans on this.
We dropped them by 80% to 90%.
In some cases, 100%. And then we've got a lot of experience showing that
we're enhancing the priming and activation of new tumor
immunity. So this is a very important
checkpoint axis, we believe, mechanistically distinct from PD-1,
PD-L1 blockade, potentially complementary to it.
So we tried this in humans. We built a first-generation
molecule we call E602. It was a human sialidase
Fc dimer.
People ask the question, "How could this be safe?
You're taking off all the sialic acid in the body." But we actually had
a high Km sialidase, which is only active where sialic
acid is abundant.
And this is a molecule that we had showed single agent
preclinical activity in multiple workhorse models of
immuno-oncology. It's comparable to PD-1.
Actually, they're very indistinguishable.
So we took it into the clinic, and we showed safety.
We showed proof of mechanism. We were desialylating tumors.
We showed the right
cytokine profile. There was no cytokine storm.
We were seeing almost like a checkpoint signature.
And then this profound effect on CD163 macrophages in paired
biopsies. But we only saw a modest clinical activity and
only in the hypersialylated patients.
And then what we realized was through paired biopsies, that our
desialylation was only lasting a couple of days on tumors.
And so we felt that this may be insufficient to sustain immune
activation. We had seen some activity, but not enough to take it forward.
Also, everybody wants single agent activity, and so the
absence of this ADCC, ADCP functionality we think
was a limitation. And then rather than killing the molecule,
actually, we decided to take it forward in autoimmunity, where CD163
macrophages play a huge role in the perpetuation of
chronic inflammation and fibrosis in autoimmune diseases.
And so we're actually in phase two in a study in membranous nephropathy around
this biology. But what we did is we found a new place for
this molecule, and then we figured out how to make the molecule better.
And so what the targeting arm does, compared to
the last one, it does several things.
First of all,
by having a targeting arm and a immune competent
Fc, we get direct killing, which we didn't get
before. The sialidase is still doing the same thing to the innate and
adaptive immune system. We're getting the dramatic reduction in the pro-tumor
macrophages. We're also getting enhanced priming and activation of T cells.
And then lastly, the targeting arm, what it does is it increases the depth
and durability of tumor desialylation to prolong the
effects that we think were too short-lived with the first generation.
And so where we decided to take this first was B7-H3 expressing
tumors. So as many of you are well aware, B7-H3 is one
of the most overexpressed tumor antigens out there across many
tumor types. We layered onto that an analysis
of hypersialylation. So we have a toolkit called
Hydra that can quantify hypersialylation on tumor
samples, and the blue diamonds are showing the percent of hypersialylation
in these same tumor populations. So as you can see, there are many
tumors that have both B7H3 overexpression and
hypersialylation. So broad potential across
multiple cancer populations. We're particularly interested in these
ones where it's over 50% of both, notably
ovarian, lung, and prostate.
So our molecule is a B7-H3 targeted sialidase.
We had the B7-H3 targeting arm. We have the active Fc,
and we have the new next generation human sialidase, which is actually
more potent than the first generation as well.
Here's our peptide sequence.
First disclosure.
And
what's the results on it?
I had to show it.
Anyway, so what's the difference between a non-targeted
versus targeted? Here's data in a tumor model
where we're comparing the untargeted and targeted
desialylation depth and duration.
So the Y-axis here is PNA. This is a lectin that measures
galactose. When sialic acid is removed, galactose
gets exposed, the PNA signal goes up.
So as you can see here, we're having a dramatic increase in desialylation
and dramatically more durable. We think this is going to make a huge
difference. And then in terms of in vivo models, we ran several.
Here's just one highlight showing that the targeted is dramatically
better in this A375-bearing humanized NCG
mouse, also compared to PD-1.
So we felt this was a strong mechanistic rationale for
advancing this type of molecule into human trials.
So where do we go first? Everybody wants to see single-agent activity.
So what we wanted to do is take an indication where there's high unmet need,
there's an IO-responsive tumor type ideally, but where you
could get anti-PD-1 naive patients.
Obviously, we need a high B7H3, high hyposialylation.
It would be great to be in one of these diseases where there's known
correlations with hyposialylation and poor outcome.
And so platinum-resistant ovarian cancer came to the top of the
list. So obviously, as we all know, poor outcomes in this
disease, you still can get anti-PD-1 naive
patients. So there's, in many places around
the world, limited prior IO exposure.
90% have B7H3 expression. About
two-thirds have hyposialylation.
So this is a snapshot of a collection of nearly
100 ovarian cancer patients with their hyposialylation
scores, and roughly two-thirds have hyposialylation.
And then in the literature, there's many
publications describing CA125 and
hyposialylation linked to poor outcomes.
We think this would be the best disease to go first to
test the hypothesis.
So our roadmap is to demonstrate single-agent activity in that
setting,
but we'd like to expand into other B7H3-expressing
hyposialylated tumors. So lung, non-small
cell, and small cell, notably prostate, but there's many others,
colon, many of the GI tumors, head and neck as well.
One thing about this molecule is we've already demonstrated with the high
KM sialidase, this is a very safe molecule.
And so what it offers us, in contrast to ADCs, is an opportunity
to move to first-line combinations without a major safety hit.
We'd like to systemically expand out the platform as well
and go after different TAA targets and then other formats,
including T cell engagers and other bispecifics.
So what we have is a molecule, which is the anchor
oncology molecule out of a new platform of targeted
sialidases, which we think is a major new way of
going after immune evasion in solid tumors that basically
people missed because everyone's so focused on protein targets.
You just focus on protein targets, you're going to miss the
post-translational modifications such as glycosylation.
So we just didn't have the lens to see this really, and Bertozzi
was the one that really put the light on it and
showed how important this area of biology could be.
So we think this is a very important axis of immune evasion.
A lot of support now directly accessible
through the work that we've done at Palleon.
Our first-generation molecule did show some activity, showed
safety and proof of mechanism, but it really helped us figure out
what to do next. How do we get better results?
Why weren't the results better the first time?
And this dual idea of a
durable tumor surface desialylation and then
also adding the immune combinant Fc were critical innovations.
So the new molecule satisfies both of these,
and we're initiating a first-in-human trial with the
safety lead-in and expansion to platinum-resistant ovarian cancer,
as well as maybe possibly others.
So the key takeaway here is this is a whole new category.
We're not an ADC, we're not a checkpoint
blocker. We're actually going after a whole new target space
of glycosylation in cancer, and we think it's mechanistically
distinct, potentially broadly applicable, it's
safe, and could be the next new class of
important cancer immunotherapies.
If you're around, I know a lot of people will probably leave by Wednesday, but if
you're here on Wednesday, we do have a poster from 9:00 to
12:00 in the morning. And just special thanks
to our whole team, to the folks at Stanford who came up with the ideas,
all the folks back at Palleon in
Massachusetts, and our partner Henlius in China, who's been such a
great partner for us in the CMC
area as well as clinical development and strategy.
So that's it.
Great. And
for questions, please come to the microphones in the center.
I can start with one. That was a great talk.
If, say, PK
is lost or a drug is removed, how quickly do you get the
re-glycosylation
back on the surface?
Yeah.
And does it replenish to the same level after the desialylation?
Yeah, it's a great question. And that's one of the things about this whole new
target space. The PK/PD relationships are
different. We're disrupting avidity.
So principally what we learned the first time was that on
tumors,
the sialylation was coming back in two or three days.
That was faster than predicted. On immune cells in immune
environments, it's longer. But for tumors, this is a very
important mechanism of immune evasion. So it came back quickly.
And so that's why what we had to do is figure out how to create the
durability. And by durability, what we did was we basically, by
adding a targeting arm, we get much, much deeper desialylation
and more durability, and we can keep it below this threshold of
where the immune suppression comes back for up to a week or
longer. Where before it was just a couple of days.
Great.
It's a great question.
All right.
Okay.
That's it?
I don't see any other questions. Thank you very much.
I-
Oh, Shiva. You want to go?
Hi, Shiva Malik from Novartis. Interesting
mechanism. I'm just wondering, in the model that you showed, that A375, I
think it was a xenograft model. I assume
it was immunocompromised. But do you understand
what the mechanism of that single agent activity in that context is?
Is it primarily ADCP? Is there a desialylation going on
there? What's driving efficacy?
Yeah. So animal models, as you know, are tricky, immune oncology.
So we had developed
all the classic workhorse models for the non-targeted
in syngeneic models and showed single-agent activity with durability.
So in the end, we were satisfied with answering the question
about the
adaptive immune side. But the new
model was more around the innate side, right?
So adding a tumor-targeting arm in that model system, you don't
have the same adaptive response. But we
figured there would be an ADCP
effect.
All right.
Thank you very much, Dr. Broderick.
It is my pleasure to introduce Dr. Sunib
Jagani. She's a director at the Oncology Disease Area
at Novartis Medical Institute in Boston.
And
she is going to be presenting today on
ECI-830,
a potent and highly selective CDK2 inhibitor for treatment of
HR-positive and HER2-negative breast
cancer and CCNE1 amplified tumors.
Thank you very much to the organizers for giving us this great
opportunity to present on the discovery of
ECI-830, which is a highly potent and selective CDK2
inhibitor.
So these are my disclosures.
Now by way of a brief introduction, the cyclin-dependent
kinases, or CDKs, play a key role in
regulating the cell cycle. In particular,
CDK4/6 and 2 control the
G1 to S-phase transition when cells are committing
to DNA replication. Now, this is occurring in a highly
coordinated process where active cyclin
CDK complexes will phosphorylate key substrates
such as the tumor suppressor Rb, and this in turn will
release the brakes on the E2F family of transcription factors,
consequently promoting gene expression to prepare
cells to enter the S phase. Now in cancer, this
highly regulated network is disrupted, and an
example of this is cyclin D. Cyclin D
levels are strictly regulated in normal cells.
But in
cancer cells, cyclin D overexpression is known to be a recurring
feature in tumors, particularly also in
hormone receptor-positive breast cancers
where the potential for exploiting cell cycle targeting
has been best demonstrated with the successful
development and application of CDK4/6 inhibitors.
So in hormone receptor-positive breast cancers, we
know that targeting estrogen receptor signaling with
endocrine therapy
is a really important part of the treatment.
However, because estrogen receptor signaling plays a key role in
driving and feeding into the cell cycle, combination with
CDK4/6 inhibitors is also a key part of the treatment
strategy. And this is demonstrated
with ribociclib, our CDK4/6 inhibitor,
which importantly demonstrates
an increase in median overall survival
in this metastatic breast cancer patient population from the
MONALEESA trial.And so, while
this clearly represents a very exciting and significant
treatment advance in this space, I think we all
appreciate that progression continues to remain
a clinical challenge.
And so what can we learn about resistance mechanisms
as well as features that can influence the extent of
response to these current treatments?
And so we currently understand that there are various
mechanisms that have been described in response to these treatments
that include both genetic and non-genetic mechanisms.
And in the class of the cell cycle alterations, what we
know is that RB loss is a clear mechanism of
resistance to CDK4/6 inhibitor. However,
as we currently understand, the frequency of RB loss is
rather modest. And this therefore suggests whether there's
continued opportunity to further exploit this cell cycle
targeting axis in this space.
Now, related to this concept,
analysis from the MONALEESA trial actually
interestingly revealed that cyclin
E1 was retrieved
in a survey of prognostic modeling using baseline
gene expression data from the MONALEESA trial.
And to illustrate this more specifically,
what is seen is that tumors that have
relatively high expression of cyclin E
in fact, do benefit from the ribociclib
combination. However,
the PFS benefit is less than in
tumors that have relatively lower levels of cyclin
E1 expression.
And so altogether, these observations begin to suggest
again, is there an opportunity to further target the
cell cycle
for deeper suppression and for improved PFS benefit
in these HR-positive breast cancers?
And so to further understand this in additional contexts,
we also looked into baseline metastatic tumor
biopsies from real-world data, in which what we
observed is that first of all, there's several levels of
cyclin E1 expression,
and that cyclin E1 expression, along with
E2F pathway gene expression, is increased
in tumor biopsies following progression from endocrine
therapy and CDK4/6 inhibitors.
Now looking back into the DepMap studies, there are
several key observations here to note.
One is that
tumor types that are associated with cyclin E1
amplification, a subset, so for example, in
ovarian, have a significantly high cyclin
E1 expression and far higher than what is
observed in these ER-positive breast cancer
models.
Now, given that cyclin E drives
CDK2 activity,
these tumor cell lines are also highly dependent
on CDK2, and in fact, because of their
really high level of cyclin E1, and the way in which they're
wired, they're predominantly CDK2-dependent.
Now, this is quite distinct from ER-positive breast cancer,
where we know CDK4 is the predominant
dependence.
And so putting this all together, there is an extremely
important hypothesis that has been introduced also
by others in the field. And that is whether
the addition of CDK2 inhibition on top
of CDK4 inhibition can yield
this deeper suppression of the cell cycle towards more
durable responses in HR-positive breast cancer.
And so clearly this has attracted a great deal of
interest towards discovering CDK2 inhibitors.
However, this has historically remained quite challenging
because of the high homology among CDK family members,
in particular CDK1, which we know is
essential in healthy proliferating tissues.
And so there's been a great amount of investment in trying
to address this challenge. And so here,
we're very pleased to share with you the discovery of
ECI-830.
So ECI-830 is a highly selective and potent
CDK2 inhibitor.
It's a type one ATP competitive orally
available inhibitor. And as we can
see, it has a high level of selectivity
versus the key anti-target that I just mentioned,
which is CDK1. And it also
displays high selectivity against additional
CDK family members, but also more broadly
across the kinome.
ECI-830 also displays the anticipated
cellular activity, whereby there's potent suppression of
phosphorylated Rb in cyclin E1 amplified
models.
And in in vitro drug property tests,
ECI displays very good solubility,
high permeability, and low cross-species
clearance, altogether making for a molecule that
has very favorable drug-like properties.Now,
to further understand the interaction of ECI-830
with CDK2,
X-ray crystallography of ECI-830
bound to CDK2 cycling E complex was
resolved at 2.5 angstrom resolution.
And this structure reveals some key
interactions of ECI-830 with CDK2,
and that also provide a hypothesis for the high level of
selectivity that is seen versus CDK1.
Now, zooming into this ATP binding pocket
and drawing attention
to this lower hinge region, which is colored in yellow,
there are several things to note about this region.
So in CDK2, first of all, this region contains
residues that are unique to CDK2,
such as the histidine 84 and the glutamine
85. In addition, this lower hinge region is
also far more structured and ordered in
CDK2 than in CDK1.
And so what this affords is an opportunity for
ECI-830 to form multiple
weak interactions that reinforce each other.
And in particular,
in terms of the different areas of the molecule, the ether
pyrazole motif engages this lower hinge
region through a hydrogen bond network.
On the other side of the molecule, the lactam
engages the well-known catalytic lysine
33 residue, and there forms weak
interactions through a water-bridged hydrogen bond network.
And so the hypothesis being that these weak but multiple
interactions are working to reinforce each other and
selectively target and engage CDK2
while sparing CDK1.
In addition, this amino pyrazole
lower hinge architecture affords improved ADME
properties.
Now, next, we wanted to really examine whether
ECI-830 has the ability to
elicit a deeper cell cycle suppression in combination
with ribociclib in HR-positive breast cancer.
And so with that, we have observed
quite
repeatedly that ribociclib, as well known,
reduces phosphorylated Rb in these
HR-positive breast cancer cells.
And the addition of ECI-830 to
ribociclib further suppresses this
phosphorylated Rb. Now, to measure the downstream
consequences of this suppression,
E2F target gene expression was evaluated, and the
addition of ECI-830 to ribociclib
further suppresses these E2F target genes.
In addition,
this is also associated with an increased fraction
of cells that are undergoing a G1 cell cycle arrest.
Now next, ECI-830 was tested in a full
dose response matrix together with
ribociclib across multiple ER-positive breast
cancer models. And what we can appreciate is that across
these multiple models, the combination of
ECI-830 with ribociclib produces
a greater combination benefit than ribociclib alone.
And this is also seen in an ER-positive breast cancer
cell line that has an ER mutation.
Now, in order to see the potential for this combination in
an in vivo setting, ECI-830 was then
tested in ER-positive breast cancer
tumor xenografts.
And here what's shown is this
ER-positive MCF7 breast cancer model
where ECI-830 was dosed orally
with a BID dosing schedule, and it was dosed both as
single agent as well as in combination with clinically
relevant doses of ribociclib. And what was really
striking to see is that the addition of
ECI-830 significantly enhanced
and increased the tumor growth inhibition that is observed over
ribociclib in a dose-dependent manner.
And this was associated with the
expected deeper suppression of phosphorylated
Rb.
So this was very promising to see this.
And further, looking at steady-state unbound
plasma PK, what we can observe is that
the trough concentrations need to be above the
phospho-Rb AC50 threshold in
order to observe efficacy.
Now, we also wanted to examine the effects of this
combination at the pathway level.
And so, doing unbiased gene set enrichment
analysis from RNA-seq from these tumor PD samples
gratifyingly revealed that the top-scoring pathways were
actually cell cycle pathways.
And importantly, the E2F target gene pathway, which
clearly shows the on-target
activity of this combination. Now, specifically looking at
the E2F targets, looking at the entire gene set, we can
see that ribociclib decreases E2F target
gene expression, yet the addition of
ECI-830 to ribociclib
further decreases this E2F
pathway.And so altogether, this
data suggests the potential for ECI-830 in
combination with ribociclib, and the team
has done additional studies in more
HR-positive breast cancer models, including ones that are
resistant to therapy. And we'd like to draw your attention to a
poster that's going to be presented tomorrow by the team
that documents these additional findings.
Now, as has indicated earlier, CDK2
dependence is also seen in the cyclin E1 amplified setting.
And so we wanted to examine whether ECI-830
has any activity in these additional settings.
And so with that, ECI-830 was tested in a
cyclin E amplified ovarian model.
And here, single agent activity with the BID
dosing schedule shows tumor growth inhibition in a
dose-dependent manner, and this also corresponds with the
consistent suppression of phosphorylated Rb in this
model.
These findings were then recapitulated in an additional
cyclin E amplified model, in this case, a lung cancer model.
And here again, single agent activity of
ECI-830 causes significant tumor growth
inhibition and very pronounced decrease in
phosphorylated Rb. And so together, these studies
also suggest the great potential to apply
ECI-830 in these cyclin E1 amplified
settings.
So in summary, here we've presented on the
discovery of ECI-830, which is a novel
CDK2 inhibitor.
It's a very potent and selective inhibitor with favorable
drug-like properties. We've also shared a hypothesis for
the high level of selectivity versus CDK1 as
afforded by structural insights and data.
We've also shown promising preclinical data to support
potential for the CDK2 combinations in HR-positive
breast cancer, whereby we have shown that the addition of
ECI-830 to ribociclib leads to enhanced cell
cycle control and efficacy. And so this is
really promising for continuing to shape and
build superior clinical combination strategies in a
space that we remain highly committed to.
In addition, ECI-830 has potential
application in cyclin E1 amplified cancers, yet
another group of tumors with very high unmet medical need.
And so we're pleased to share that ECI-830 is
currently in phase one clinical studies as a single
agent or in combination in patients with advanced
HR-positive breast cancer and other advanced solid
tumors.
And of course, this presentation would never be complete
without a strong acknowledgment of the incredible and
talented team
that has really driven these discoveries and made
all of this work possible. And again, I'd like to
remind, if
time permits, to please attend the team's poster session,
again, documenting additional very exciting and insightful
data on ECI-830 that we did not have the time to review
here today. So I'd like to thank you for your attention
and happy to take questions.
We have time for one or two questions.
Hi. Carlo Toniatti from IRBM Italy.
A very interesting talk.
One quick question. Maybe I missed one point.
So this compound has a double-digit
nanomolar activity in vitro in the assay.
But
if I have correctly captured one data, so even in
cells, in phospho Rb, the activity is still 10
nanomolar or something like that.
So you don't see a potency shift,
which is something that you would expect for an ATP
competitive. Again, maybe I missed something.
Yeah. So thanks for the question. So,
in that table we see potent biochemical activity.
There's a shift when you go from biochemical to cell.
In cells, so for example, the phospho Rb in the
cyclin E amplified setting is about 100 nanomolar.
So there's that shift, but it's still very potent.
And that actually corresponds very well to the anti-proliferative
potency, which really closely aligns with the phospho Rb,
which again, as we know, is a very clear proximal PD
marker for this effect.
Yeah.
Sure.
Thank you.
Please join me in thanking her again, and we'll
have to move on to our next talk because we're at time.
All right. We continue on with an exciting theme for
today. Another disclosure we have upcoming of a
molecular glue, this time from Dr.
Vito Palomba, who is the chief scientific
officer at Triana. And he will be speaking
today about TRI-611, a
potent selective CNS penetrant ALK
molecular glue degrader for the treatment of ALK-fusion
protein positive non-small cell lung cancer.
So welcome, Vito.
Thank you very much.
I'd like to thank the organizers for choosing us to present our
work on TRI611.
These are my disclosures.
So ALK is a receptor tyrosine kinase that's very
important in embryogenesis and neuronal development.
Its expression in adults is limited.
However, in certain cancers, it is fused to
other protein partners, leading to the cytoplasmic
localization as well as the constitutive activation
of the kinase. This leads to tumorigenesis,
has been seen in a number of cancers, especially non-small cell
lung cancer, and it also is very important for tumor
growth and survival, in maintaining tumor growth and
survival.
A number of tyrosine kinase inhibitors or
TKIs have been developed or are in
development to treat this disease.
These TKIs have had a profound
impact on the disease, including patients with
CNS metastases. However,
you do get resistance to these TKIs, and when you
get resistance, the only therapy option available is
chemotherapy, as immunotherapy is not active in this
setting.
So at Triana, we asked the following question:
Can a molecular glue degrader of ALK fusion proteins provide
an orthogonal approach to treat ALK-positive non-small
cell lung cancer?
So in order to do this,
we used our E3 pairing engine and
identified cereblon as an E3 ligase
that we could utilize to actually develop an ALK
molecular glue degrader.
And so to first find a molecular glue,
we took a proximity approach where
we took
ALK kinase domain
and our proprietary cereblon library, and using a
TR-FRET assay, identified a number of hit molecules.
Shown here is a particular molecule that we
followed up on because we felt very strongly that
this molecule had the potential to cross the blood-brain barrier
and enter the CNS.
Importantly,
all of our hit molecules
induced weak proximity,
and they were devoid of any degradation activity.
So with multiple rounds of SAR
following and using structure-based design, we
identified our development candidate, TRI611,
as shown here.
On the upper right-hand panel is the proximity assay that I just
described, demonstrating that ALK and
cereblon
can be induced to come together
by TRI611.
Also,
in this panel, we demonstrate that
TRI611 is selective for ALK
in that it does not glue closely related kinases of
ROS1 or the TRK family of kinases.
Also, we used an orthogonal SPR assay shown on the bottom,
and you could see that TRI611
induced the ternary complex formation between
ALK and cereblon.
This is the cryo-EM structure of
TRI611 with ALK in the
cereblon DDB1 complex.
You can see clearly that TRI611 here
binds at a site on ALK distal from
the ATP active site, as well as it will not
interfere with ALK fusions.
Also, it binds to a site on
ALK that is less conserved, suggesting
that it will actually be selective for ALK over
other kinases in the kinome.
Zooming in,
this is the interaction site between
TRI611, cereblon, and ALK. What you can
see is that cereblon is engaging a novel
helical degron on ALK. This is not a G-loop
degron.
Here, we demonstrate that this unique degron, along
with its broad surface area, suggests that it will be
selective over cereblon neosubstrates, and it will also be
selective against other kinases in the kinome.
As TRI611 induces the proximity
of ALK to cereblon, it leads to polyubiquitination
and degradation of EML4-ALK.
In the panel on the left-hand side, you see in vitro
ubiquitination induced by TRI611,
demonstrating functional competency of TRI611.
In the middle panel, we demonstrate that
TRI611 stimulates the degradation or
induces the degradation of full-length endogenous
EML4-ALK. We also show that this is
cereblon dependent
because in these cells, we have knocked out cereblon and we can now
block this degradation. And on the right-hand
side, it demonstrates that this degradation is proteasome
dependent.As
I mentioned, ALK was selective against closely related
kinases. But we performed an unbiased
proteomic analysis to examine the selectivity of
TRI-611 in an ALK-positive
non-small cell lung cancer line. And that's shown on the left.
Only EML4-ALK protein is degraded.
There are no other proteins that are degraded in this
line. In fact, we also tested it in
an ALK-deficient cell line, and you see no
proteins degraded at all in that context,
indicating the selective nature, the highly selective
nature of this TRI-611 as a
selective molecular glue degrader for ALK.
We next tested TRI-611 in vivo.
Here we used a
non-small cell lung cancer xenograft
expressing EML4-ALK,
and we treated the tumor-bearing mice
with TRI-611 orally, daily for
21 days. You can see a really nice
dose-dependent regression of the tumors,
and if you look on the right-hand side, that
tumor regression correlates with
greater than 90% EML4-ALK
protein degradation.
Looking at the kinetics of this degradation in this tumor type, this
is following a single oral dose of
TRI-611.
You see rapid, deep, and durable
degradation is shown in the blue boxes, and it does not fully
recover by 72 hours, even as the
plasma exposure wanes, as shown in the red
circles.
As I mentioned, TRI-611 binds to a
site on ALK that's distal from the ATP binding
pocket, and it's also distal to where TKIs
bind and where there are TKI resistance
mutations in and around the active site.
So we used the BAF-3 system to
explore, in a broad way, the
anti-proliferative activity of TRI-611
in BAF-3 cells that are overexpressing a
number of known as well as predicted ALK
TKI resistance mutations.
This is a heat map
showing
the results
versus wild type EML4-ALK. The more
yellow, the more sensitive, the more blue, less sensitive.
What you can see is that TRI-611 is
active against all of the mutations that we
have put into this system. It's active against all
these TKI resistance mutations.
This is in contrast to lorlatinib, where you see a
shift in potency, especially in the double and
triple mutants.
To expand on this,
we looked at TRI-611's activity in a
lorlatinib-resistant model. Here, the canonical
double mutation 1196-1202 was
knocked into the EML4-ALK locus in
NCI-H3122 cells.
We then explored the activity of TRI-611
in these tumors, as well as the parental tumors.
And what you can see is, again,
TRI-611 had
potent and dose-responsive effects in
inducing the regression of these tumors.
Whereas lorlatinib only worked in the
parental cell line.
I point to a poster that Matt Harlow is going to be
presenting on Tuesday afternoon, where he'll go into
a lot more detail with respect to the activity of
TRI-611 on these particular mutations.
We also explored the activity of TRI-611 in
a patient-derived xenograft.
Again, we see nice tumor regression with oral
dosing of TRI-611, and it
correlates with greater than 90% reduction of
EML4-ALK protein, as shown on the right-hand side.
As I mentioned,
patients with ALK-positive non-small cell lung
cancer
have developed CNS metastases.
And we know that TRI-611 is
brain penetrant in a number of different
preclinical animal species. So we
explored the activity of TRI-611
in a luciferase-tagged ALK-positive non-small
cell lung cancer
intracranial xenograft.
The tumors were allowed to grow for approximately 20
days,
and then they were randomized and treated
with TRI-611 or lorlatinib orally.
Luciferase was measured, and what we see in the left-hand
side is that, in fact,
TRI-611 causes the reduction in the
tumors.You get
really nice dose-dependent
regression in this intracranial tumor model with
TRI-611,
and it's very similar to the activity that's seen with lorlatinib
in this model.
We use lorlatinib here that gives the
clinical exposure in the mouse.
Importantly,
this model also we explored
pharmacodynamic effects to look at whether or not
TRI-611 would lead to the degradation of
EML4-ALK in the brain tumors.
And so what we show here is a two-day PD
assay
where you see complete
degradation of EML4-ALK by
TRI-611. It's noted by the brown
staining. You see that there is no more
EML4-ALK present
when the
animals were given TRI-611.
It's also important to note that when we looked at the brain
exposure of TRI-611 in this model, it was very
similar to what we observed with lorlatinib.
Finally, as I mentioned,
TRI-611 and ALK TKIs bind to the
ALK kinase domain in different places.
This suggests that we could
combine both drugs to get
enhanced activity.
So to explore this, we ran an experiment where we
combined
TRI-611 with
lorlatinib in both subcutaneous as
well as intracranial ALK-positive non-small cell
lung cancer xenografts.
We use sub-efficacious doses here of both
agents in order to see the enhanced activity when
combined.
Suboptimal doses of either agent alone clearly
show and demonstrate tumor growth inhibition.
However, when you now combine both agents, you
see really nice tumor regression.
We have a lot more to present around this, and I point you to Andy
Connery's poster on Tuesday morning, where he'll
explore a lot more around our combination
potential.
So in conclusion,
I've demonstrated here that we feel strongly that a
highly differentiated ALK-targeted molecular glue
degrader can provide that orthogonal approach to
treat ALK-positive non-small cell lung cancer.
We first aim to establish
TRI-611's monotherapy activity
in
patients that are TKI experienced.
Because of the highly differentiated
nature of this molecular glue degrader
and the fact that it has remarkably clean
preclinical safety profile, we're very excited to
explore TRI-611 in combination
with other therapies, especially ALK TKIs.
I'm happy to say that TRI-611 is currently in a Phase 1
clinical trial, and we've recently received US
FDA Fast Track designation.
So it takes a village to develop a therapeutic, and
I have to thank all of my colleagues at
Triana for all their hard work and dedication to get this
program to where it is today.
I also want to thank and acknowledge my
Dana-Farber colleagues for all the work that they helped us do with
the PDX models. And with that, I thank you for your
attention.
Congratulations. Very exciting program.
Thank you.
I was wondering if you could, since you got the Fast Track designation, can you
elaborate a little bit on the safety profile?
Are you seeing any signs of neurotoxicity?
So we're not going to elaborate on
our preclinical safety, but just to say it's
remarkably clean.
ALK is not really expressed in adult tissues.
Thank you. Great talk.
Thank you.
So most of the data that you showed was for EML4-ALK, and you
did mention at the beginning and end that there are other fusion partners that ALK
works with. Can you comment on the degradation efficiency of your molecule
with other ALK fusion partners?
So first, we've looked at other variants of
EML4-ALK and see really nice degradation as well as activity in
those tumor models. We have also explored
full-length ALK with an activating mutation.
We see really nice degradation of the full-length protein.
Great. Thank you.
Hello. Very nice talk. I'm very interested in the
discovery of your TRI-611 based on the
proximity of the compound one. So I would like to
ask, what's the compound one's ternary binding and
degradation results? And what data
make you decide to make and screen compounds
with extension based on this compound one structure?
Thank you.
Couldn't understand the question. Did you understand?
What are your thoughts on compound one as a starting point?
Oh, compound one as a starting point?
Yeah.
Compound one as a starting point, as I mentioned, was a very weak
proximity inducer. There was no degradation that we
observed with compound one.
Okay.
Our medicinal chemist did a lot of work,
using structure-based design in order to build
out our molecules and as well as identify
TRI611.
Yeah. I believe that there
must be a lot of compounds with different structures in your
library.
Yes.
So my main question is, what data makes
you decide, to make more
compounds extended, based on this compound
one rather than other core structures?
I think as I mentioned,
the reason we actually went with this particular
group of hits was because of its propensity or what we thought
our ability to get into the central nervous system.
So
we didn't want to start building molecules and then have to go back
and then try to get it into the central nervous system.
So that's why we
actually went after this particular group of hit compounds, where we
did a lot of medicinal chemistry before we landed on
TRI611.
Okay, thank you.
That non-G-loop degron that you
saw for
these
compounds that are bringing together this complex, do
you see more of that degron throughout the
proteome and can you expand on what it- So not that
particular degron, but
the answer is yes, there are
structural degrons that are not G-loop degrons for other
proteins, for sure.
Great.
Oh, very nice talk. I have a question that, so your compound
can bind all the different
mutation of ALK. So is that because it's bind a different
area where the mutation happen?
Yes. It binds distal to the active site where the
TKIs bind, and where all of the mutations that
are in and around the
active site of the kinase. Because we bind
distally to that, we're capable of actually
degrading all the different TKI resistance mutations.
Yeah. So, my next question will be, since it's a different binding
site, so is that possible you can conquer all the
resistance that happened with this ALK
inhibitor, including the new mutant of the compound?
Do you have any data about resistant cell line or models that
the inhibitor have, then you can still have efficacy?
Yes. So we have shown that all of
the known and predicted TKI
resistance mutations
are sensitive to TRI611. All of them that we have
tested.
So have you compared to new mutant compound?
So we have.
You have?
And we see very similar activity.
So do you have a model that the new mutant compound is not working and your
compound is still working?
We'll show that somewhere else.
Okay. Thank you.
All right. Unfortunately, we need to stop the
questions.
Thank you.
But thank you very much, Vito Palomba.
And now we go back to ADCs. Please join me
in welcoming Megan Rice from AstraZeneca, and she's going
to present on the discovery and development of a CD30 dual
payload ADC that combines MTI and
TOP1 inhibition. Thank you.
Thank you both for having me today, and thank all of you for joining
me. Let's get started with this.
Okay. Historically, systemic administration of
chemotherapeutics has stood as the standard of care, despite their
limited therapeutic window.
To expand upon this therapeutic index-
I'm too short, so...
Okay.
To expand upon this therapeutic index, targeted therapies have
been pursued with the expectation that if we can
direct our drug to the tissue of interest, we can reduce
the amount that is required to drive efficacy,
and by limiting off-target interactions, we can improve our
safety profile.
But these therapeutics have their own challenges.
For example, if we take a closer look at antibody drug conjugates,
traditionally, these have been generated by using either
lysines or cysteines for conjugation.
The problem is that there are many lysines
and cysteines within an antibody structure.
This limits our ability to control not only the number of
drugs attached, but the site to which they are attached.
In response to this, we are experiencing a shift in the
industry.
Companies are pursuing next-generation conjugation chemistries
that afford us more control.
Some are pursuing enzymatic approaches,
transglutaminase, catenase.
Others have taken the approach of glycan remodeling,
reconfiguring the sugar group so that they can attach to it,
typically by click chemistry.
And for us, we are using a non-natural amino acid
platform.All of these technologies afford
us precision engineering,
precise control over conjugation site, precise
control over the number of drugs that are attached,
precise control over stability of our conjugates.
And as an added bonus, they are orthogonal chemistries.
They allow us to attach not one, but two drugs to the same
antibody.
Now, the advantages of dual payload ADCs, the list is as long
as my arm, but they've only given me 15 minutes.
So I've shortlisted a few of my favorites.
For starters, they allow us to address heterogeneous tumors.
They allow us to overcome mechanisms of drug resistance.
And ultimately, they allow us to drive more robust tumor regression.
CD30 is a target that is amenable to these approaches.
As a single-pass transmembrane protein
coming in at 120 kilodaltons, there is ample real
estate for antibody binding.
And it's a robust internalizer, which is desirable for antibody drug
conjugates.
Furthermore,
it is highly overexpressed in a number of cell types across
both Hodgkin and anaplastic large cell lymphomas, and
that expression profile is consistent throughout all stages of disease
progression.
The one caveat to CD30
is that there are several known mechanisms of drug
resistance that have been reported in CD30
positive cells.
Otherwise,
a very appealing target for ADCs.
It came as no surprise then when brentuximab vedotin was approved in
2011.
BV is a stochastic DAR4 MMAE conjugate,
meaning that it is an antibody where they have used the native cysteines
to attach four monomethyl auristatin Es.
It's a microtubule inhibitor.
And it's achieved great success with an overall response rate greater than
75%, truly.
However,
similar to other MMAE ADCs that have gone through the clinic,
unfortunately, it has had its limitations because of drug
resistance mechanisms.
So with all of this in mind, we set to work
engineering our dual payload ADC.
We started with an antibody that binds CD30 with
high specificity.
We incorporated our non-natural amino acid into our protein
by way of a mammalian expression system.
Our non-natural is a canonical lysine that has been
functionalized with a spirocylopentadiene.
It enables Diels-Alder cycloaddition.
It is the non-natural amino acid that we have used to attach two
MMAEs. Not four like BV, just two.
In addition to that, we use the native cysteines to attach
eight topoisomerase one inhibitors.
Now, we had very specific things in mind when we
were designing our drug.
In cutting down the MMAE load, we had hoped
that by reducing that toxin, we could improve the tolerability
profile, and knowing that our chemistry is
stable, irreversible under normal biological conditions,
we should indeed be able to reduce that cargo load and still
expect to drive robust tumor regression because we would expect
to reliably deliver our cargo to its target.
Now, as far as the topo is concerned,
we wanted to make sure that we had a clinically relevant,
clinically validated dose,
and of course, there is always the matter of balancing our therapeutic index.
We want to drive robust tumor regression without compromising our
pharmacokinetics and our,
ultimately, safety profile.
After we had finished construction, we got to work characterizing our molecule.
We started in vitro. So our top two panels here,
we are looking at binding and internalization.
We wanted to make sure that interaction was specific, so we
looked at a number of different cell lines across both Hodgkin's and anaplastic
large cell lymphomas. And you can see in the figure on top right,
they have varying receptor densities.
And we do see a nice, strong correlation
between our internalization rate
and the copy number.
One step beyond that, we went into in vitro cytotoxicity, and we looked
at several models,
both sensitive and insensitive models.
We were able to confirm in vitro that we retained activity in
our resistant models.
Furthermore, we used an H2AX assay to confirm that
our efficacy was indeed driven by our payload.
Next step was to take our molecule in vivo and confirm
that these trends did persist. So we started by evaluating
two different models.
On the left-hand side, we have a Hodgkin's lymphoma model
with a receptor density of roughly 80,000 copies.
And on the right side, an anaplastic large cell lymphoma model.
Double the copy number, just over 160,000.
And in both cases, we see that our molecule drives robust tumor
regression at clinically relevant doses.
Then we got into the fun stuff.
So I know this is a busy slide. We'll take it nice and slow.
The top panel is an anaplastic large cell lymphoma
lineThe bottom panel
is that same line, but we have engineered it to overexpress
P-glycoprotein, an efflux pump that is known to effectively
pump MMAE out of the cell, limiting its
efficacy.
So if we start all the way over on the left-hand side of the slide,
we have brentuximab vedotin. As expected,
in the top panel,
it drives efficacy.
But in the bottom panel, engineered to overexpress that efflux
pump, we see that BV has little to no activity.
In the next column, this is our DAR2
non-natural amino acid control, so only MMAE.
And we see a similar effect. We see that in the sensitive
model on top, we do indeed drive regression.
In fact, despite having half the DAR,
we see a little bit better regression.
Again, likely attributed to the stability of our chemistry.
But when we get down into the resistant cell line, we see the same effect.
We have no activity with MMAE alone.
In the next column,
we have topoisomerase alone, so just our DAR8.
And in this case, we have tumor regression in both models, exactly as we had
hoped.
So we see regression in the parental as well as the cell line
engineered to overexpress PGP.
But the exciting part came with our next column. This is our dual payload ADC.
And not only do we see that we have activity retained in both models,
as we had expected since the topo did so well,
but I'd like to draw your attention to the red line.
Red line is our suboptimal dose. At 0.6
milligrams per kilogram, you'll see that none of our single payload
ADCs had much of a response in the parental or the
resistant line.
But our dual payload ADC has a robust
response at that suboptimal dose.
This was the first time that we really thought
this confirmed this assumption that there would be a benefit to
co-delivery, to ensuring that we're delivering both
cytotoxins to the same cell.
The next step, we were feeling very good at this point.
The next step was to go into safety studies.
So we started with a single-dose rat tolerability study.
Now, to break this down for you, we included BV in our
first study.
We wanted to learn as much as possible about the tox
profile, and so we included it at 10 milligrams per kilogram.
The reported maximum tolerated dose is 18
milligrams per kilogram. So that's the dotted line in that
plot.
The red bar, that is ours. Our dual payload
ADC
had not only maintained, if not improved upon the efficacy,
but it was tolerated at 60 milligrams per
kilogram.
We were pleasantly surprised. It seemed a little too good to be true.
So of course, the first question was PK.
In transitioning from mouse to rat, had we experienced an abrupt
difference in our pharmacokinetics that perhaps gave us this
misleading profile?
Maybe it was being rapidly cleared instead.
So the team set up a PK study, and we evaluated
pharmacokinetics in rat.
And we were pleasantly, I guess, relieved to see that that was
not the case.
Our PK profile did indeed translate.
We have a nice long half-life.
In fact, a little longer than BV,
and our molecule is stable. It retained its linker
payloads.
So
we proceeded into a multi-dose study, a dose range
finding study, and we were able to confirm that even in a multi-dose
regimen,
our tolerability was 60 milligrams per kilogram with our
dual payload ADC.
Okay, to summarize, our next generation conjugation
chemistry has allowed us the opportunity to generate
ADCs with improved biophysical properties.
That stability translates to improved pharmacokinetics and ultimately
better function.
Beyond that, we were able to confirm both in vitro and in vivo
that we can drive tumor regression in models across both Hodgkin's and
anaplastic large cell lymphoma,
and in both sensitive and resistant models.
We have initiated our non-human primate study,
and while I was not able to disclose it today, I can say that
our preliminary readouts look very promising at clinically relevant doses,
and as such, our phase one planning is underway.
And of course,
I'd like to thank the team, a few members of which are here today, but it was an
all-hands-on-deck effort, and
thank you for your time.
Go ahead.
Hi, thanks. Nice talk.
It looked like both of your payloads were terminated in maleimides, so I was
wondering how you control the ratio
of different payloads onto your construct.
Great question.
So when we start our conjugation process, we
start with the non-natural amino acid.
At that point, we have not uncapped our cysteines, so
we can ensure that the maleimide is going to
interact with our spirocylopentadiene.Then,
after we have gotten rid of any free payload, we proceed with
uncapping the cysteines and making them available for the second conjugation.
So it's done stepwise.
Thank you.
Evgene Gagu from Weill Cornell. I really enjoyed your talk.
How can you explain, in the dual ADC payload,
the fact that the microtubule inhibitor is no longer recognized
by pIg-like protein?
That's a great question. I don't know that it's
not recognized.
I guess our speculation-
Not recognized.
What's that?
Stays inside, so it must be not recognized.
Yes.
Okay. So our speculation has, up until this point, been
that we're bombarding the cell. We're
overwhelming it with two different mechanisms that can direct cell
death.
I don't think that is it. Maybe look further, because even
if you are bombarding them, if one of the two compounds is
pumped out, is not recognized, effectively you only get one
inside the cell. So maybe it gets
masked or something else.
Perhaps. All things that our translational team is going to be
working very hard to address.
Thank you for sharing your data and idea.
I have a question about your
choice of
tumor type.
I might miss from your talk, is it for hematological cancer, right?
Yes.
And then, is there any particular reason you chose
hematological cancer, not solid cancer, for making your payload ADC?
No, there's not a reason why we started there.
This started as a tech dev program.
We wanted to see if we could build it first, and we wanted to start with something
for which there was a clinical benchmark available, something that was
well-known, well-studied, validated, for which there were tools,
and CD30 was a great candidate for that.
Thank you for that.
Hey, very nice talk. I was curious if you could share your
insights on the MTD of your ADC, because
for MAE-based ADCs, the MTD is
usually much lower than 60 mg per kg.
So what aspect of the dual payload
approach do you think really improved that MTD?
I don't think it's the dual payload component.
I believe it is the chemistry that is used to conjugate the
MMAE. That chemistry is stable, as
opposed to thione-lamide conjugation chemistry that is
conventionally used, which is subject to Retro Michael.
It is unstable. And that mechanism of payload loss is very
important for driving off-target toxicity.
So I don't think it necessarily has anything to do with having two payloads on
board. It's more about how we have attached the MMAE.
So how much payload loss do you see with this approach?
With non-natural chemistry?
Very, very little. Barely detectable.
It is highly stable, and based on where we have
put it on the antibody,
we're able to rely on the protein to shield it as well.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Hi. Great talk. I want to ask if you
have tried using your unnatural amino
acid stable platform, but
dosing mono payload,
both MMAE and Topo I at the same time to
compare with dual payload?
Yes, absolutely. Great question.
We have done some work evaluating combination therapy of the two
independent ADCs, so the DAR2
MMAE with the non-natural and the stochastic Topo
DAR8.
And the outcome varies. It is dependent on a couple of
factors. So first,
it depends on how we dose it. So if we, say, dose molar
equivalents of payload versus dosing
the same amount of antibody, we get different effects.
Also, it depends a bit on the receptor density.
So if we're working with a cell line that has a very high receptor density, then
the combination therapy does pretty well.
But when we get into cell lines where there are fewer receptors to bind,
then we see that the dual payload prevails.
Thank you.
Sure.
I think we have one more.
Really great talk. Thank you so much.
Could you talk a little bit about the transferability of the technology as
you showed today to other payloads, given the great data you showed?
Hmm, great question. Well, I think that
the key is going to be exploring payloads,
understanding their behavior independently, and then ultimately
trying to pair them not only with each other, but with the
appropriate biology, so that you're really making
best use of their mechanism of action.
So I do think that it translates. I have reason to believe that other
combinations can be made.
But it is not going to be a one size fits all.
It will be target dependent.
Join me in thanking Megan and all of the other speakers.
Thank you.
And just a reminder, we have session three tomorrow
morning at 10:15, and in the afternoon, we have the
joint town hall. So lots more coming from the
Chemistry and Cancer Research Group.